[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الا ليت شعري هل ابيت لنا ليله بوادي
القرى اني اذن لسعيد ولقد اجر الذيل في
وادي القرى نشوان بين مزارعين
ابيات شعر جميل بن معمر الملقب بجميل
بثينه والحجر احد الاماكن التي شهدت حبه
العذري لمعشوقته بثينه فجميل بثينه عاش
بالعلا ووثق حبه بين جنبات وادي القرى احد
مسميات العلا سابقا هو شاعر ومن عشاق
العرب
[موسيقى]
قصه حب جميل لبثينه تعود بعدما راها وهو
يرعى ابن اهلها جاءت بثينه بابن لها لترد
الماء فنفرت ابن جميل فسبها ولم تسقط
بثينه وانما ردت عليه اي سبته ايضا وبدل
من ان يغضب اعجب بها واستملح اسبابها
فاحبها واحبته وعنده يمكن القول سترت
اللحظات الاولى في قصه هذا الحب العذري
الخالده
[موسيقى]
العلا من المعروف انه ساكن فيها الجميل
بثينه جميل عاش في هذا الوادي الجميل
واغرم في هذا الوادي وابدع كما ابدع باقي
اهالي العلاقه جميل يمكن في احد بيوت له
يقول
الذيتان ليله بوادي القرى امنيه لسعيد
نفسه بالسعاده والنشوه انه عاش في العلا
وفي وادي القرى ولو كذلك بيت شعر يقول
ولقد اجره الليل في وادي القرى نسوان
في منطقه وهو من اسماء العلا الاسماء
القديمه جميل طبعا ااه ابن عبد الله بن
عمر عاش في وادي القرى
[موسيقى]
الحب العذري تمت تسميته لانه منسوب الى
قبيله عذرا وهي قبيله عربيه كانت تعيش في
فتره ما قبل الاسلام ابنائها يتميزون
بحسهم المرهف والمشاعر وعشقهم ايضا للنساء
وصدق العواطف بل انهم كانوا يموتون حبا في
محبوباتهم فمر رجل بعربيا فساله من اي قوم
انت فقال من قوم اذا احبوا ماتوا
[موسيقى]
العلا تعد بلد العشاق في مدينه الحب
والتاريخ يتم توفيق التراث الاصيل فالقطاع
الثقافي في البلاد بدا بتتبع اثار جميل
بثينه باعتباره مؤسس المدرسه الادبيه التي
تطورت الى فن غنائي وصفي بائع الصيت بين
العرب لصباح العربيه